[Music]
what's going on guys we got ourselves a
sonic trailer sonic 2 sonic harder
enjoyed the first one it was cute
john big sonic fan biggest sonic fan
i've ever known it's the only game i'll
ever play only game he's ever gonna play
it's downhill from there for him oh
rolling down hill
all right guys let's see let's see if we
get ourselves so here knuckles is
supposed to be in this right and who
else hails hails to tails yeah miles per
hour tails let's get to it guys and see
what's in store ben schwartz baby
he hears that every time he enters the
room
[Music]
quick stretch little snack and here we
go
sorry i love that you want to help make
a difference
[Music]
[Music]
trust me there will come a moment when
your powers will be needed
wow jeez that moment
there's some emerald in there wait a
second did you steal that from oprah
there is
[Laughter]
papa's got a brand new stash
since i've been gone i discovered the
source of ultimate power yeah
the master emerald
it's been on my vision board for years
damn face
yes sorry who are you
tales okay
okay
like taunting step two i have no idea
[Music]
that wasn't too bad
[Music]
today's forecast calls for a one hundred
percent chance of adventure hey they're
back different bar actually
wow they really
[Music]
do i look like i need your power
looks badass yeah
where
are my manners sonic meet knuckles
damn
[Music]
start a petition for redesigns on
on uh to tails right now guys yeah and
knuckles starter petition yeah i know it
looks great make them more realistic now
yeah less cartoon life we could do a
multiverse of the cartoon like in the
realistic photo realistic version yeah
yeah slap them into one universe and
then in part three we'll cross over with
the animated 2d characters it'll be
perfect oh do it dude whole universe
encompassed i'm not gonna lie
why not so i'm just gonna keep my mouth
shut
no sugar
can't say nothing nice trailer look made
it look like an improvement on the
direction of the franchise it's massive
it's really big stakes but you do get a
better sense of the peril i like seeing
like knuckles there he really lived up
to like the hype surrounding him because
man he does have a presence and he does
look intimidating he does look genuinely
really cool to behold this feels more
along the lines of what i would want the
sonic world to evolve into because i
know the last one was like a fun little
road trip movie and uh yeah jim carrey
being jim carrey he's essentially just
doing that here as dr robotnik still but
raising the stakes of that the different
characters from the sonic world coming
together feels like bigger more whimsy
more kinetic it feels more like sonic to
me than the last one did and i'm sure
that movie did get a lot of criticism
and overall it did have a pretty good
reception though with audiences so it
makes sense that they've got a sequel my
point being is that i'm sure they've
taken a lot of what was criticized and
they want to make it even better more
exciting and it seems like that's
exactly what they're doing i really like
this trailer i was pleasantly surprised
i think it's gonna be great i don't know
it looks more along the lines of what i
wanted the first one to be yeah it looks
like they're taking both the fun you
know jokey tone and then just the action
in general and ramping both of those
things up you know keeping sonic because
yeah this youthful presence but who
still can like kick a lot of ass and
stuff yeah uh and yeah this is
interesting because it seems like with
these movies i mean they're definitely
leaning into parts of the cartoon
because in the cartoons they're like
more prone to like hanging out with
humans and helping out with their
problems you gotta do it uh yeah and so
this looks like it's maybe bringing in a
little more of the fantastical a little
more of the realms that sonic actually
comes from because you've got these like
temples with this you know big emerald
on top which i think has got to be the
master emerald which there's a thing in
the games with these chaos emeralds and
there are i think seven of them and they
grant you like power over time it's like
a lot like infinity stones so i'm
curious to see if they're gonna do a
thanos thing with egghead here with dr
robotnik it looks like a lot of fun and
too to get these characters jumping in
like with tails they're going to do like
an origin for the two of them because i
think in the games when you meet tails
they're just best buds already it's
still going to be a buddy movie between
tales and sonic yeah whereas like last
time when it was james marston so i'm
glad they didn't do that thing where
they're just like let's just ride out
james martin
yeah but he's definitely seeming like
he's taking a major back seat at this
one yeah he has a little bit of a role
enough to set up the theme for the movie
where he's talking with him about
there's gonna be a moment where your
powers are gonna be needed but you don't
choose that moment that moment chooses
you he's gonna be there to set that up
and he'll probably come in at some point
again but for the most part this seems
like a globe trotting adventure yeah i
think that's kind of the word i was
looking for i don't know exactly how
much how how far the exploration is
going to go the last one was like the
midwest or something yeah
and then eventually i ended up in the
city so i felt more small and i think
sonic lends itself to going bigger like
that yeah and i think the setup of this
movie if i'm remembering correctly is
like james mars and antika sumter like
leave him at home alone and that's when
the adventure starts so i have to
imagine that there will be a lot of
opportunities for sonic to stretch his
legs and getting knuckles in here too
like you know idris elba from the brief
snippet of a voice over moment that we
got from him i'm excited because it
seems like you know knuckles at least in
the cartoons and stuff has like you know
that badass voice as compared to sonic
but it doesn't sound exactly like idris
elba either it sounds like he's putting
on at least a bit of a character
inflection which excites me and two i
think her name is colleen o'shaughnessy
they actually got the real voice actress
who does tails oh no way yeah so it's
like the one instance of an actual and i
mean a lot of people have voice tales
but you know she's particularly well
known for it and so they brought her in
you know nice to see somebody who
originated or helped you know build the
voice of that character actually brought
into the big hollywood movie version
yeah yeah excited to see how their
rapport happens especially because now
they have to build that friendship in
this movie and you know tails will have
to sort of step up as the sort of tech
you know sidekick head and then dr
robotnik looking more like actual dr
robotnik probably going to be much more
crazed and demented now than ever before
let's just hope more of the jokes land
this time
yeah that's all you can hope for right
guys what'd you think about sonic 2
sonic harder leave your thoughts down
below are you excited to get your sonic
on subscribe click that bell say hi to
christ last but not least let's do a pic
michael linden in my fan casting of
sonic you are my egghead man i think
that it is time for you you're a
mild-mannered thoughtful guy but i know
you've got greater ambitions michael you
should be out there exacting your master
plans all right you just need a source
of power that's the catalyst that's the
key but you've got it within you to be a
dastardly villainous character i just
think you could be such a sexy beast in
a mustache especially like the crazier
the mustache the better and dude i mean
you're already from across the country
of the world from us and i mean if
there's anything i've learned from
american movies it's that people from
other places besides america are usually
quite villainous so i feel like you know
you would be the shoo-in to maybe be
like you know grandpa robotnik or
something in the part three version so
true you know when they finally reveal
uh some of the origins of like shadow
the hedgehog they bring him in man you
could oh dude you would be so
perfect mikhail so uh get your mad
science on you know maybe even get
yourself in like a lab accident or
something to give yourself like that
extra dose of insanity because you know
if everybody ever lives through like a
laboratory accident they just become
insane i think that'd be a good look on
you buddy hope your holiday season is
going well i've been waiting for a
giveaway for john to pause so i could do
my bit but uh you've been talking for a
minute and a half so thanks raquel